well this is where you i think previous
time
we talked about where you poetically
uh disagreed with my naive uh notion
about humans
i i just think that humans will make
this whole driving thing really
difficult
yeah all right like i said humans don't
move that slow
it's a ballistics problem it's a
ballistic humans are ballistics problem
which is like poetry to me
it's very it's very possible that in
driving they're indeed purely a
ballistics problem i
and i think that's probably the right
way to think about it but
i still they still continue to surprise
me those
and damn pedestrians the cyclists other
humans and other cars
and yeah but it's going to be one of
these compensating things so the
like when you're driving you have an
intuition about what humans are going to
do but you don't have 360 cameras
and radars and you have an attention
problem so yeah so
so the self-driving car comes in with no
attention problem 360 cameras right now
a bunch of other features yeah so
they'll wipe out a whole class of
accidents
right and you know you know emergency
braking with radar and especially as it
gets you know ai enhanced will eliminate
collisions
right but then you have the other
problems of these unexpected things
where you know you think your human
intuition is helping but then the cars
also have
you know a set of hardware features that
you're not even close to
and the key thing of course is uh if you
wipe out
a huge number of kind of accidents then
it might be just way safer than
a human driver even though even if
humans are still a problem that's hard
to figure out
yeah that's probably what happens
autonomous cars will have
a small number of accidents humans would
have avoided but they'll wipe
they'll get rid of the bulk of them
you